the next prime minister of this country
kirst armor that's the hope now the hard
yards Labor's leader today embracing the
task ahead and looking like he means
business these elections really really
matter and we've got to go out and we've
got to win them to do that Starman needs
to secure Council seats in Swindon and
Beyond calling on the government to
freeze council tax as he kicks off his
local election campaign
but the path to the general election
already firmly on his mind important
moment for you in the quest to win a
general election right yeah they are
they're very important
um for a number of reasons when you come
out of these local elections on May the
5th what does Victory look like well
look we want to take everything we
possibly can in these local elections
they're very very important to us but
I'm measuring this on the road into the
next general election you've got to show
you're in serious contention I'm putting
it to you that what I'm looking at is
whether you can get over a thousand
seats is that fair well look we want to
get as many of those thousand seats as
we possibly can I'm measuring the
progress from the general election 2019
to the general election in 2024. the
2019 general election under Jeremy
corbyn Labor's worst performance in over
80 years this labor lead of preventing
his predecessor from standing at the
next a drastic attempt to close the
Corbin chapter for good you described
German Corbin is your friend and now
you've kicked him out there's one person
who is responsible for the fact that
Jeremy corbyn will not be a labor
candidate of the next election and
that's Jeremy corbyn you're prepared to
be ruthless to win I'm prepared to be
ruthless to ensure that we have a labor
government I have been ruthless in the
change in the labor party but people
here are not yet fully convinced you
think they're going to win the council I
think there's a real hope that they will
yeah but like many towns there's a big
divide and
um lots of people I think still will
vote for Kevin for the consent he comes
across trustworthy but the proof of the
pudding is it's not so you're in
government is it to me there's an awful
lot of showing but I don't hear them
coming up with a remedy
fix what he's talking about
this campaign firmly underway but
there's still a lot of ground yet to
gain and time to go Beth Rigby Sky News
in Swindon